*upbeat french accordion music*
I mean I like a lot of Pixar movies too.
I love Pixar movies.
Oh yeah, like Shrek is my all time favorite.
Or like Rio 2.
Ohhh, Rio 2.
Oh, more of a Turbo guy?
Oh my God, I haven't seen one of these since we were kids. It's so cute. And my nephew loves this.
So I think you'll find these pie charts to be quite delicious.
ahahaha, oh my glob you're so lumpin' funny.
So anyway we're bankrupt.
So have you seen ParaNorman.
I love ParaNorman. Wait have you seen Coraline.
Attack on Titan?
Les Triplettes de Belleville
Animaniacs
Ahhhh Real Monsters!
Guys can we talk about Game of Thrones?
Man: Last night Women: I know right.
It was amazing!
Uhm did you guys see Bob's Burgers last night? Cause it was so good. Tina, she's like my spirit animal.
Is that like a reality show?
Is it on TLC?
Uh no, it's... uh just never mind.
Anime?
Yeah!
Like school girls and tentacles?
No it's not all about school girls and tentacles. It's like, ok.. two of.. some... Mad Men.
You like Mad Men?